because financial literacy is a big
problem it sure is in this country
actually financial illiteracy is what's
illiteracy that's what's taught
is if if that's possible it's possible
to teach illiteracy
i mean you start out illiterate you'll
be taught to read and become illiterate
but i actually think
most of what's taken for granted
is actually taught illiteracy
my best example of that is when the
consumer spending data comes out every
month
you know there's always a big cheer if
there's a lot of spending
and there's a extra loud cheer if that
spending
is based upon a huge increase in debt
because what they say is oh this is a
wonderful sign because it shows that
that consumer is confident confidence
yes
and so a huge
uh pile of debt gets twisted
into a positive thing and remember i
used to work inside the fed
yeah you hear this all the time i mean
that that
you know like like home ownership is
certainly preached but most people never
own their home
well that's the thing home ownership
it's they're just renting
the renting for another 30-year lease
because
even now we have huge refinancing that's
going on oh yeah
we're actually back to almost 2003
levels for some of the cohorts that were
recently
recently written and these people
may have been i mean most of these
people are probably only a few years in
but they're people that are 10 years
into their mortgage
and then they re-up for another another
another 30 years you know there's i
think i i think i heard that
some almost impossible sounding fraction
of retirees actually have mortgages oh
gosh yes
which just shows you how incredible i
want to say it's close to 20
it's incredible how is that possible
that's
that's that's servitude that's not
retirement
so there's a lot of financial illiteracy
a lot and
and it keeps getting pushed i mean
there's a new there's a new class in
financial
literacy that was just rolled out i
think this year it's ever smaller
participation vehicles into the stock
market
there's this thing called slices now oh
where you can actually buy
five dollars of a stock right and then
i think there's an advertisement on some
financial media where they say you can
be diversified with
ten slices for only fifty dollars
and and i think first we had the the
futures contracts
then there were the mini futures
contracts and then there's the
the many many contracts to allow a
broader base of participation from less
and less
sophisticated people well but i mean are
they learning anything
they're going to learn they're learning
how they're going to learn
through the school of hard knocks
you